et
[Musique]
l'orchestré symphonique de montréal a
ouvert sa saison 2018 2019 avec un opéra
de chambre intitulé tshakapesh le
périple du fripons oui vous avez fait la
narration en innu puis qu'est-ce que ça
signifie pour vous c'est une très belle
expérience très belle expérience
quelques que je vis à à travers ce
projet fonctionne mais utaka baisse
jeudi dernier comme si tu continues
ghanam strauss kahn bien obtenu je suis
sorti de nos j'étais un géant comme
comme comme tagab est d'ordinaire
[Musique]
le 18 septembre vous allez accompagner
justement le sm dans nord du québec pour
présenter chaque à pêche le périple du
fripons aussi cela est important pour
vous non symbolique
l'impressionnant quand même c'est moi je
on est rendu là je crois je pense qu'il
ya quand même une ouverture maintenant
le fait d'amener un groupe de musiciens
à l'intérieur des terres on va dire ça
comme ça c'est fabuleux et en bourse
écrivent les plus lourdes sont natasha
khan ap fonsat élisapie ya plein de
jeunes artistes qui font vraiment leur
place de jeunes artistes thorton parce
qu'en quelques secondes vous vous sentez
plus que reçoit dans tout ça parce que
vous étiez là bien avant
oui yoyo qu'ashton la tornade
il a trente ans d'autres c'est laurent
en été oui parmi à être connu
matthew à travers le pays
[Musique]
le
je crois qu'on a amené quelque chose on
a amené au début on était une curiosité
mais après et les gens ont voulu savoir
plus nos origines
on a fait découvrir 11 nations du québec
québécois je sais que les gens sont mis
à s'intéresser
[Musique]
par les temps qui courent on parle
beaucoup d'appropriation culturel
oui on vient pas perdu sur kanata s'ils
disent ils entendent moi j'ai été
bousculé par pas par ces choses là et se
sait on apprend droit à l'erreur carton
de raconter l'histoire de l'autre on n'a
pas tout à l'heure
[Musique]
puis je donne comme exemple et signe un
artiste de l'alberta s'associe avec un
américain pour raconter l'histoire du
québec et aller le présenter à las vegas
sans consulter personne est ce que les
québécois réagir et mettant juste la
partie de la crise d'octobre
si on a mené sa taille a raconté par
d'autres je pense qu'ils auraient une
réaction des ischios ici en ce qui
concerne j'ai très hâte entend de la
musique qui va aller avec soin
il doit rue musique qui vient
j'ai eu d'entente
gerda temps je curieux de voir est ce
que sa voix qu'est ce que ça va amener à
nos enfants
c'est aussi la question que je me pose
quel espoir avec vous pour les
générations futures
je rêve que que nos enfants soient
encore plus fier que nous que nous on a
été je peu tanné de d'être une victime
j'aimerais ça avoir un autre rôle
j'aimerais me et je souhaite un dans le
futur que que nos enfants aient une
vision
de même autre que celle d'une victime à
la barre
merci beaucoup du cerveau
je tape soutien
[Musique]
et
m